on se croirait presque dans le film top
gun mais nous sommes en réalité sur la
base aérienne de tours à l'école de
chasse et d'aviation chaque année ici
une cinquantaine d'élèves viennent
d'apprendre les ficelles du métier les
élèves vont avoir à découvrir notamment
la la voltige aérienne donc des
évolutions en trois dimensions l'endroit
à l'envers qui ne sont pas des
évolutions destinées à faire briller les
yeux du public hélas c'est pas du tout
dans leur mission c'est de se préparer à
des manoeuvres de combat nous être
capable d'évoluer dans les trois
dimensions de manière à s'orienter pour
effectuer une passe de tir une manoeuvre
sur un appareil qui serait hostile pour
un pilote d'escadron entre les exercices
de vol
les cours et le sport chaque journée sur
la base ressemble à un véritable compte
à rebours
car tout s'articule autour d'une mission
donnée avec une heure et un objectif
précis première étape donc le briefing
d'avant vol faut vraiment que notre
leader soit à gauche de votre tête haute
pour avoir cette sensation de couper à
l'intérieur la trajectoire est d'être la
bonne distance au moment du tir d'accord
d'accord s'il n'est pas cette position
là vous n'aurez pas la bonne distance au
moment du tir c'est notre avantage sur
les jeunes élèves c'est que nous on a
l'expérience donc mais qui va se passer
quelque chose
on sait déjà à peu près comment il faut
réagir alors que l'eau ils vont
réfléchir beaucoup voilà j'ai une
situation que je connais pas qu'est-ce
que je peux faire et là ils vont perdre
du temps ils vont être le mois précédent
pilotage parce que ce qui est difficile
à fond une fois le briefing terminée et
l'équipement de combat enfilé ses sur le
tarmac que ça se passe avant chaque
mission les appareils des alphajet sont
inspectés à la loupe
les pilotes eux installés dans leur
cockpit font le vide ils sont déjà dans
leur volume très concentré sur en
semaine dans la mission du briefing pour
pour rien et c'est farid et de presse au
doute en fait on se remet morize les
différentes actions qu'on va devoir
faire d'abord pour être sûr de rien
oublié notamment comme vous l'avez dit
niveau de sécurité il ya des points très
importants qu'il faut pas oublier en
moyenne les élèves pilotes reste huit
mois en formation à l'école de chasse et
d'aviation de tour avec près de 200
heures de vol au compteur avant de
s'envoler vers une autre base